HERE TOMORROW NIGHT,
TUCKER CARLSON COMING UP LIVE
FROM WASHINGTON, D.C., RIGHT NO
NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," IT'S
HALLOWEEN SO TODAY OF COURSE
CONGRESS TOOK ITS FIRST OFFICIAL
STEP TOWARD IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT.
THE HOUSE VOTED 232 TO 196 TO
APPROVE A RESOLUTION THAT LAYS
OUT RULES FOR THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS, IT WAS NEARLY PERFECT
PARTY LINE VOTE, EVERY SINGLE
REPUBLICAN VOTED AGAINST IT, ALL
BUT TWO DEMOCRATS VOTED IN FAVOR
OF IT.
ADAM SCHIFF MEANWHILE THE
CONGRESSMAN FROM BURBANK WAS
ECSTATIC, HE HAS SPENT YEARS
OBSESSING OVER IMPEACHMENT LIKE
IT WAS A YOUNG JODIE FOSTER.
COLLEAGUES SAY HE HAS PICTURES
OF IMPEACHMENT TAPED TO THE
WALLS OF HIS BEDROOM, HE'S
WRITTEN LETTERS WITH HIS OWN
BODY FLUIDS.
IF FOR SCHIFF IT WAS THRILLING,
WATCH HIM HERE PRETEND IT WAS
NOT THE HAPPIEST DAY IN HIS
ENTIRE ADULT LIFE.
>> THIS IS A SOLEMN DAY IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT'S MISCONDUCT HAS
COMPELLED US TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH AN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
WE TAKE NO JOY IN HAVING TO MOVE
DOWN THIS ROAD AND PROCEED WITH
THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
NEITHER DO WE SHRINK FROM IT.
>> Tucker: WE TAKE NO JOY IN
THIS.
OF ALL THE MANY LIES TOLD AT
PUBLIC EXPENSE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND THERE ARE
MANY, THAT MIGHT BE THE MOST
HILARIOUSLY BRAZEN OF ALL AND AT
LEAST A GENERATION FOR THOSE OF
YOU KEEPING TRACK AT HOME.
IN FACT, FOR DEMOCRATS,
IMPEACHMENT IS LIKE WINNING THE
LOTTO ON CHRISTMAS BUT BELIEVE
US NOW, WE ARE NOT ENJOYING IT,
NOT EVEN A LITTLE BIT.
WE ARE PRAYING FOR YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT -- THAT'S NOT REAL.
WHAT IS REAL AS THE PUBLIC IS
NOT LOVING IT QUITE AS MUCH AS
ADAM SCHIFF IS, NEW POLLING
APPEARS TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHMENT IN SOME DECLINE,
IT'S POSSIBLE VOTERS ARE
CONFUSED BY WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHAT ARE THE CHARGES HERE?
HOW DO WE GO FROM DISLIKING
TRUMP TO TRYING TO JUST
TRUMP TO TRYING TO RUST
TRUMP TO TRYING TO REMT
TRUMP TO TRYING TO REMOVE HIM BY
FORCE OVERNIGHT AND WHO EXACTLY
IS THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER?
WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS
TO THOSE THE MOST BASIC
QUESTIONS.
LAST NIGHT THE SITE REAL CLEAR
INVESTIGATIONS PUBLISHED AN
ARTICLE, AND SCHIFF IS NOT
DENYING THE SUBSTANCE OF THAT
PIECE, PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION CORROBORATES SOME OF
THE DETAILS -- THE MAN IS A
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT WHO WORKED
IN THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
AS A HOLDOVER FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
OVER THE YEARS HE WORKED FOR
JOE BIDEN AND DISGRACE CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN.
A NEWS ARTICLE FROM 2017
IDENTIFIED HIM AS PRO-UKRAINE
AND ANTI-RUSSIA, SAID HE WAS THE
SUBJECT OF BITTER COMPLAINTS
FROM SOME REPUBLICANS WHO KNEW
HIM.
TWO YEARS AGO CONSERVATIVES WERE
PUBLICLY CHARGING THAT THIS MAN
WAS WORKING FROM INSIDE THE
BUILDING TO UNDERMINE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
ACCORDING TO THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS INVESTIGATION PIECE
LAST NIGHT, THEY WERE RIGHT.
THE MAN WORKED AS A PROFESSIONAL
LEFT-WING ACTIVIST TO ATTACK
DONALD TRUMP, HE HELD MEETING
WITH ADAM SCHIFF'S STAFF MEMBERS
SEVERAL OF WHOM ARE HIS FORMER
COLLEAGUES FROM THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
TONIGHT WE CAN TELL YOU IT SEEMS
LIKELY THIS MAN WAS ALSO A
SOURCE FOR ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION, WHAT APPEARS TO
BE THE MAN'S NAME CAN BE FOUND
IN THE FOOTNOTE OF THE FINAL
REPORT.
A WEEK AGO "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PRAISE THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AS "A
PATRIOTIC PUBLIC SERVANT," HIS
AIM THE PAPER REASSURED US WAS
NOT TO BRING DOWN MR. TRUMP OUT
OF PERSONAL OR POLITICAL ANIMUS
BUT TO RESCUE THE REPUBLIC FROM
HIS EXCESSES.
IF REAL CLEAR'S PIECE LAST NIGHT
IS ACCURATE, THAT FRAMING IS AN
UTTER LIVE.
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WOULD BE
MISLEADING AND IT WOULD BE
PROPAGANDA LIKE SO MUCH WE HEAR.
IS THAT?
ONLY ADAM SCHIFF CAN CLEAR IT
UP.
HE SHOULD DO THAT IMMEDIATELY
FOR THE SAKE OF RESTORING
CONFIDENCE IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT BUT HE WON'T DO THAT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SERVE HIS
POLITICAL INTEREST BUT IN SOME
WAYS IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF WHETHER HE'S A SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER OR NOT, THE MAN
REAL CLEAR ROAD ABOUT WAS A
NAKEDLY PARTISAN POLITICAL ACTOR
AND WHAT SHOULD BE A
NONPOLITICAL POSITION, HIS JOB
IS TO PROTECT THE UNITED STATES.
HE HAS SPENT HIS DAYS TRYING TO
GET HIS TEAM ELECTED.
THAT IS WRONG BUT UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL.
DEPUTY CIA HEAD JOHN
McLAUGHLIN ENCOURAGED
BUREAUCRATS IN WASHINGTON TO
CONTINUE TO SUBVERT ELECTED
OFFICIALS, THE ONES THAT WORKED
FOR.
>> THANK GOD FOR THE DEEP STATE.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
EVERYONE HERE HAS SEEN THIS
PROGRESSION OF DIPLOMATS AND
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS AND
WHITE HOUSE PEOPLE TRIPPING UP
TO CAPITOL HILL RIGHT NOW AND
SAYING THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THEIR DUTY, RESPONDING TO
A HIGHER CALL.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT COULD SHAKE THE PUBLIC'S
FAITH IN THE GOVERNMENT MORE
THAN FORMER CIA -- OF ALL